good morning john a couple of weeks ago
somebody mentioned me in the comments of
this tick tock
i was just doing my makeup for work and
i just wanted to tell you guys
about how i don't think math is real and
i know
that like it's real because we all like
learn it in school or whatever
but who came up with this concept and
you're like pythagoras
but how how did he come up with this how
would you even figure that out how would
you
like start on the concept of algebra i
was immediately excited by this because
this young woman
is asking all of the right questions to
not just lead to a greater understanding
of math
but actually joyous understanding of
math and i get frustrated that
oftentimes the way we teach math right
now
ignores these questions how did
pythagoras a dude who didn't have a
flushable toilet
figure out an equation that we still use
and is still useful
today thousands of years later a truth
so true that it is more
true than reality is every point in our
universe
has some bluntness every line has some
wiggle but in pythagoras mind
there was a perfect triangle one that no
matter how far you zoomed in the lines
were straight the points were pointing
one in which for
every right triangle the area of the
square made by the hypotenuse
was exactly the same as the area of the
squares made by the legs of the two
triangles added together
exactly exactly now there's the question
of
how he figured this out there's a number
of thoughts about this we're not sure
the one that's most discussed is that he
was looking at a bunch of square tiles
and he thought if i split one of those
squares diagonally
then i get a triangle and the legs of
that triangle well the squares made by
them
are right there the they're those
squares there and the square made by the
hypotenuse well it's made out of
triangles if i split these other squares
but if you add those triangles we just
made up you get the two
leg squares and then he abstracted that
not just to triangles made by squares
but all kinds of right triangles the
point though is that he didn't need any
special knowledge to figure this out he
didn't need any special technology
he just needed to play a game in his
mind they say he was like visiting a
palace i think he was pooping
i think 90 chance he was pooping now the
pythagorean theorem
is useful information like it comes in
handy for people
it doesn't come in handy for me that's
not why it's interesting
it's interesting because it's
interesting the idea
that we teach people the pythagorean
theorem without teaching them
that mathematicians build universes in
their minds that are more perfect than
the one that we live in in some ways
that's wild that's wild sometimes it is
brought up and sometimes the fact that
pythagoras built a cult
promising secret knowledge about this
stuff and then actually delivered on
that secret knowledge
that was extremely powerful and wild
that you can create a universe in your
mind that also is sometimes taught but
not always
i mean come on this young woman asks
does math exist
i don't know i don't know did pythagoras
discover his theorem or did he invent it
does math both exist
and not exist is it an artifact of our
minds or of reality
no one knows the answer to that question
well let's
let people ask it the most discouraging
thing is that of course because
as discussed this is an imperfect
universe people then like
mocked her as if she was stupid when
she's
asking the question the big question
math is a game it's a game we play in
our minds and i don't know
how we ended up going from like go play
go play to like remember this equation
this is how we will judge you
when we're deciding whether or not you
get to go to college so bless this young
woman for her questions
and bless kind the drag queen for
explaining mathematics on tick-tock so i
guess this universe does have some
things going for it
john i'll see you on tuesday also i
interviewed bill gates
about misinformation and internet
platforms over on hank's channel if you
want to check that out it's there
i liked it